well folks it's the Trump laptop yeah
it's you know you know with all of these
things it eventually comes back around
and really bites Republicans we are now
aware of a laptop
uh belonging to a trump aide
that contains on it
classified documents I know I know what
what about Hunter Biden what about
Hunter Biden this is really unbelievable
CNN reports that the Trump team has
turned over additional classified
records and a laptop to Federal
prosecutors wow wow
um the Trump attorneys also handed over
an empty folder marked classified
evening briefing these are additional
handovers understand still related to
what took place in December and January
and it suggests CNN writes that the
protracted effort by the justice
department from to repossess records
from Trump's presidency may not be done
a trump aide previously copied some
pages of these classified documents onto
a thumb drive
and a laptop not realizing they were
classified according to sources the
laptop which belonged to an aide who
works for Save America pack that's
Trump's scam pack and the thumb drive
were also given to investigators in
January
special counsel Jack Smith's
investigation which is pursuing criminal
charges possible criminal charges
subpoenaed Trump last May for all of
this stuff folks there's a laptop okay
it is not surprising necessarily but in
a sense it is still shocking that after
year after year and year out year and
year out Hillary's server Hunter Biden's
laptop we now discover that Trump had
people working for him
involved in the mishandling of
classified information which we knew
already but now we even introduce a
laptop element into it we need that
laptop we need that laptop and former
former Federal prosecutor Sean Wu was
interviewed by Jim Acosta on CNN
recently he said that laptop's got to be
a part of this investigation listen to
this turned over uh even more of these
classified materials uh a laptop has
also come into the picture here to
Federal prosecutors in recent months it
really underscores the enormous
difference between what's going on with
Biden's documents and pences first of
all volume of documents but the fact
that they're still finding more and the
fact that's on a laptop is a huge
security concern for that so it really
underscores why you really need a
criminal investigation of that some
questions in my mind still about why
special counsel appointed to provide and
how come still have one for Pence and
the laptop is a concern because
who knows well not only it's a concern
that was downloaded any classified
information sent some information
downloaded onto the laptop from there
it's easily transmitted it could be
copied to other electronic devices as
well so that's very different than if
you could say hey it's inside a room at
least we know where to document the
paper document was but once it goes
electronic you can go anyplace yeah now
there's another element to this as well
as I mentioned the laptop belongs
belonged to someone who worked for the
save America pack those aren't in in a
sense those aren't even political arms
in the operational sense we're talking
about a pack which just distributes
money that is raised and figures out
ways in Trump's case to funnel that
money back into his friends and family
and family members so that is not even
someone in the universe of people who
even hypothetically should be reading
classified documents so the question
we're quickly coming to and I know many
of you are frustrated and you've been
sending me emails
when is Trump getting indicted if at all
and I continue to say I don't have any
idea you may all remember that for a
period of years I came to you and I was
almost in tears quite frankly saying
Trump's not going to be indicted I don't
expect any indictment whatsoever and if
he's indicted he's not going to see a
day of jail time or prison time I admit
that in the aftermath of the search
warrant being executed at Mar-A-Lago my
view shifted us to the likelihood of an
indictment and I thought oh an
indictment seems more likely at this
point but I still maintain that Trump is
not going to see any jail time any
prison time even in the most extreme
hypothetical where Trump is convicted
and sentenced it would either be a
suspended sentence or a sentence to be
lived out at his home and that is
thinking so many years ahead quite
frankly I am now going sort of back to
where I was previously
I just don't know that an indictment is
coming I really don't and ultimately if
either way whatever consequences there
are are going to be minor and symbolic
in nature does it even matter I do think
it matters I actually think indicting a
former president would be a big big deal
it also could really throw the campaign
into further disarray which would be
great to see and we'll talk about how
that campaign is going a little later
but I share the frustration I don't know
that an indictment is actually coming at
the same time Trump might be indicted
tomorrow it's extraordinarily unclear
and in addition to that there are so
many different investigations which
could lead to an indictment that it's
very hard to know what's going on I
think the best approach is wait and see
live your life and if Trump's indicted
we will all know and we will assess from
there
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives a significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below